my name is Maria tare Tina I'm a PhD
candidate in the history of art
department here at Yale and the idea for
this conference came out of
conversations between my fellow graduate
student role in Betancourt and myself
based on our shared interest in the
formal conceptual and theoretical
connections between the art of the
Byzantine Empire and that of modernity I
am a modernist with an outside interest
in Byzantium and Roland as Abbas Antonis
who is interested in modernism so in
many ways it was a match made in heaven
we're both humbled and grateful for the
amount of support that we have received
in the past few months both within and
outside of the Yale community and as
such we have quite a few people to thank
for helping us reach this stage first
and foremost we would like to extend our
thanks to the faculty and graduate
students in the history of art
department for their support and
encouragement of this project and
especially to professor's Rob Nelson
Alexander Nemerov David Joslin and Tim
behringer who guided and encouraged us
when the conference was just a fanciful
idea advanced by two graduate students
special mention must also go to dr.
Martina Roth and professors George Soros
and Sally promi all of whom lent
invaluable moral and financial support
to us when the project was in its
nascent stage we would also like to
thank our colleagues Magdalene
breidenthal Lindsey Reardon and Samuel
ray Jacobson for helping us with the
practical logistics this weekend in
addition we would like to acknowledge
the dedication and energy of our
business manager Nicole Chartier whose
hard work was instrumental to the
success of this conference needless to
say this conference would not have
happened without the very generous
funding that we received from a number
of academic departments and institutions
at Yale many thanks must go to the
Office of the provost and of the
secretary to the dean's fund the Charles
gorilla day Trumbull lectureship the
modern Greek association and Hellenic
studies the history and his
three of our departments and the
graduate and professional Student Senate
we are likewise very grateful to the
Religious Studies department the Yale
Institute of sacred music the Martin
Kellogg Fund in the classics department
the coyote fund at the Council on Middle
East Studies at the Macmillan Center and
the European studies Council with a
title six US Department of Education
grant finally many thanks must go to the
binary library the Yale Center for
British art and the Yale art gallery
which is allowing us to use this
wonderful auditorium tonight we would
also like to use this opportunity to
thank the panel chairs and our many
speakers who have very generously agreed
to participate in the conference and
last but not least I would like to thank
my co organizer Roland Betancourt
without whose vision creativity energy
and industriousness this conference
would have never materialized and on
that note I'd like to pass the podium on
to him for a few opening remarks thank
you again for coming Thank You Maria and
I mean I just have to return all the
things that she gave me to her because
this really wouldn't have been at all
possible or have even begun if she had
not approached me and said why don't we
do something about this and it has
clearly spiraled beyond our wildest
imaginations and it's a great experience
and I'm so happy to be here today so I'd
like to just begin with some opening
remarks and introduction to the
conference and I hope that many of our
speakers will find a little bit of each
and one of them in this introduction
because you were all in mind as I wrote
this so I'll begin now